دراسه طبيه جديده حذرت من مخاطر التدخين
اليوميه واثرها على تقلص الدماغ والاصابه
بالضمور مع تقدم العمر مزبوط الدراسه التي
اجريت على اكثر من
28 وعارن فيها الباحثون بين الاشخاص الذين
لم يدخنون امل ابدا
والمدخنون او والمدخنين يوميا ليتبين ان
المشاركين الذين يدخنون على اساس يومي
كانت احجام دماغهم او ادمغتهم اصغر تضمن
هذا الاختلاف في حجم الدماغ انخفاضا
بمقدار 5.5 سم مكعب في الماده الرماديه
للدماغ التي تحتوي على الاجسام الضخمه
لخلايا الدماغ والخلايا العصبيه ويرتبط
انكماش الدماغ بامراض عصبيه مثل الزهايمر
ومن ثم فان انشاء رابط سببي بين التدخين
وانخفاض حجم الدماغ يعزز الفهم عن تسبب
التدخين في هذه الامراض
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات